[موسيقى]
لم اكن اتخيل للحظه ان هذا سيحصل في
الولايات المتحده
الحزب الجمهوري وقف متحدا خلف ترامب في
هذه القضيه واللافته كانت تصريحا مترامي
الجمهوري اللدودي لترامب الذي اعتبر ان
القضاء يستعمل تهما جنائيه من اجل التوافق
مع اجنده سياسيه ولكن يبقى صمت الزعيم
الجمهوري مش مكان المدويا في ارجاء المشهد
خاصه مع طلب ترامب من الجمهوريين وقفه
تمويل وزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي من الكونجرس
لا اعتقد ان زعماء الجمهوريين سيذهبون الى
مواجهه مباشره مع وزاره العدل كما طلب
ترامب وسبب مباشر ان معظمهم سياخذون
الانتخابات المقبله ولديهم في برنامجهم
ملفات الجريمه وامن الحدود وغيرها ولا
يريدون تعقيدات تمنع اعاده انتخابهم
وسيستكملون تحقيقاتهم ودعم ترامب ولكن ضمن
حدود معقوله
ترامب يحاول الان توجيه الاعين على القضيه
من منظار قضائي بحث معتبرا ان التهمه التي
وجهت له غير قانونيه وغير دستوريه
الان المسار الذي اتبعه المدعي العام في
نيويورك في توجيه هذه الاتهامات كله صحيح
ولكن يمكن ان يلعب الفريق القانوني للرئيس
السابق على عده نقاط مفصليه يمكن ان تشكل
مخرجا ان كان من ناحيه التقادم وسقوط
المهله القانونيه او حتى التاثير المباشر
في قضايا مختلفه
في الولايات المتحده وتؤثر بشكل مباشر على
مسار الانتخابات المحموم العمل المقبل
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن